Ryan is with us Ryan's in Bakersfield
California hey Ryan how are you good
their area better than I deserve what's
up that's an honor to talk to you and
thank you for taking my call sure help
my wife's had some debt for a credit
card that she signed for her parents
because they didn't have enough credit
at the time before we got married so
when I we went into the marriage we took
the dead-on together a few years ago we
decided that she didn't have a job at
the time and I wasn't making enough so
we decided to default on the credit
cards and kind of just put them out of
sight out of mind forgot about him until
we got served with papers from one of
the credit-card companies that they
filed a lawsuit against us to get
someone's get their enter their money
back so kind of kind of stuck point of
what we should do with that we have to
respond in 30 days and she's six months
pregnant with our second child and I
really don't want her showing up in
court and I tried to call and settle
with them and they won't take anything
less than what's owed on the balance
okay and so how much is owed on that
card that card was 1900s okay and who's
a toad - how long has it been since you
paid on it it's been probably about 2
and 1/2 years and so it was a best buy a
credit card that she son for her parents
yeah that's weird name on the account -
no they didn't put their name on it
because they wanted her there
they promised her that they would pay it
awesome also they weren't trying to
build their credit they were just trying
to borrow money using her name yeah
exactly
okay so they got the stuff and you got
the bill okay yeah so how much well
that's cause you didn't pay it but how
much of the other debt is there she's
got about $40,000 worth of school
and how much of the stupid parent the
routine debt is there there's 19 from
that and about eleven hundred from
another credit card she signed for them
I and what do you make about thirty six
thousand and what does she make about
thirteen dollars okay
and she's how many months pregnant six
looks well I'm guessing you don't have
any money no okay well here's what's
going to happen if you don't give them
money you offered to settle them how are
you gonna settle with them hoping to I
hadn't gone that far I was hoping to
yeah you probably ought to have where
you're gonna get the money figured out
for you make somebody an offer to settle
yeah okay so you're not gonna pay them
in 30 days you don't have the money
right so they are going to they have
sued her and they're going to win the
lawsuit by the way unless you pay them
off they're gonna win the lawsuit anyway
because they simply shoot her for not
paying and the truth is she hadn't paid
and they're gonna win the lawsuit the
the big the good answer is you're in
Bakersfield California so woopty doopty
they're not going to do nothing
California has got so many consumer laws
are so tied up they're in such a barrel
of fishhook so they're gonna get nothing
eventually they may try to find a way
through the courts but I doubt it
I'll give you about a about a five
percent chance that they go all the way
to trying to garnish your wages and I'm
not even sure they'll be able to do it
in California depend on how this is
structured okay so really it's it's no
big deal but but you need to get this
mess cleaned up that is a that is a big
deal cuz it's not going away dude very
you guys are you had your head stuck in
the sand and every time you stick your
head in the sand it exposes your butt
you notice that yeah yeah you stick your
butt up in there when you stick your
head in the sand so don't do that
anymore let's let's get let's get it
let's get this going to get into
addressing it and we got to clean up
these two bad debts and then we got to
start working on the student loans you
got other debts we how much do you own
your cars together they're twenty five
thousand okay and that and you hardly
make that what's that which one of those
two is the expensive one
Oh hers is the more expensive one either
do you know what do you owe on first
hers I think there's 15,000 left on hers
and you make 36 and she makes 13
and she's got 40 in student loan debt
and credit cards you couldn't pay and
you bought a $15,000 car see this is
what's going on
you just been buying everything in sight
like you were in Congress or something
so that car is gone man it's got to be
sold okay it's sighs it's not you can't
keep it it's not gonna fit in your turn
and you turning your life around plan
and I want a you turning your life
around plan you got a baby to feed
because you're scared you got to be
scared yeah well and it's stress on the
marriage I mean you start fighting about
nothing because this stuff's piled up on
you I mean Sharon and I were 28 years
old we went broke with a brand-new baby
and a toddler did we buy killed each
other it is not good for a marriage I'll
just tell you so we're gonna do I'm
gonna help you I want you two to go
through our class Financial Peace
University it's a one-year membership
and you go to nine Lessons I'm gonna pay
for it
okay all right if I give it to you will
you go absolutely all right and then you
plug into Everett Lee every dollar app
in the in the class and it'll show you
how to run the app how do your budget
and connect to your bank and do all that
you get all that for a year you've got
online access to everything for a year
to watch the videos and you go to nine
lessons and a local church in your area
and we'll get you set up for that for
free how old are you two guys that's
what I was thinking I figured you were
early thirties yeah about what you fit
and so it's just time for you to change
don't you think yeah so here's what
we're gonna do when you get everything
moving then you're going to call these
idiots back that had the best buy they
bought that debt for probably about a
nickel on the dollar so they probably
got about 150 200 bucks max in this
thing maximum and so they eventually if
you keep wearing on them we'll take a
settlement of $1,000 or so or less but
you're going to save up a thousand
dollars to be able to do that but you're
gonna lose the lawsuit before that
happens and I wouldn't worry about it
but
hold on we're gonna have Kelly get you
signed out and we're gonna get some help
here we're gonna walk with you if you
need some more help you call me back
anytime I know what it feels like to be
that scared